um and then we joked about no country
for old man yeah
i [ __ ] love this film it's a great
film it's just one of those films that's
like
yes i'm a movie critic wow i think these
are based on my list that you could say
that about me but
i do think that no country for old men
was the first film where i was like wait
you can just like make things
this ambiguous what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
i mean like it's also not easy as [ __ ]
yeah i do like my very uh kind of
open-ended ambiguous films
you know memento was one of them you
know you don't really have a film where
you follow the main character
often that that acts behaves in this
cold way yeah that you're also like
you're like come on tell me something
yeah and they just don't tell you
anything
i just let you follow the other film
that's even remotely like that is maybe
like
american psycho maybe yeah yeah yeah but
every single
like you know when you rewatch this
movie so many times and then you go and
watch like people
watched a lot yeah because it used to be
on channel four all the [ __ ] tv yeah
i did didn't know so i used to watch
all the [ __ ] time like ten ad breaks
in between yeah but like
you know you'd watch this movie and then
you'd read about it yeah and you'd be
like oh that's what that was about and
then you go back and you go
oh [ __ ] i was exactly the same with and
i was debating when to put it on but i
was like no my three by three is already
pretentious
i
david lynch is one of my favorite
directors i was like i don't want this
to be more pretentious no that's what i
was thinking as well
there's so many things in no country for
all men that i just love so much this
day like the fact that he just decides
sometimes to flip a coin
no i was i was to kill them yeah and he
went through with it like
if it if he genuinely went heads he
wouldn't like he wouldn't kill them
and it's like holy [ __ ] this man is
insane yeah like i i've gone through
this like recent phase of just like
instead of watching movies again i just
rewatch clips from movies and for some
reason like
because i watch one another iconic clip
gets recommended and like i remember
just re-watching
the gas station scene yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] what a good scene i think out
of like the entire history of movies
in terms of like tension i can't think
of a better scene than that i mean just
such a good actor as well i can't
remember the main man because he hasn't
done oh he did he was the one of the
villain in the bond movies yeah yeah but
he's terrifying
yeah he's so good in this eyes man i
know right yes
cold-blooded eyes every single dialogue
moment
that he has with anyone is just like oh
my god it's [ __ ] terrifying
that's funny that's funny you say you go
back and like watch movie clips of like
iconic movies because i have
that exact thing with uh the [ __ ]
court scene and there will be blood
where like daniel day lewis is like
doing that like insane monologue
at the courtroom and i'm like holy [ __ ]
i need to go back and watch this movie
but i can't be [ __ ] again i've
actually i've actually like there's
there's there's been the phase now where
because i've been watching a lot of
movie clips
sometimes i just watch clips from movies
i haven't seen yeah yeah and
then i end up just psychopath huh
psychopath
no because like he gets recommended and
like it's a good clickbait title i'm
like
damn that was a good scene and then i
watched another clip and another clip
and i feel like there's a lot of people
doing this now because i go to the
comment section
i go to the comments section and it's
just like i feel like it's the person
it's
people who have gone through the exact
same algorithm journey as me
because i remember going through the
comments section and it's just i feel
like i've watched this entire movie now
just through clips
and i'm just like that's just that's
exactly what i did
those poor cinema directors pour their
heart out
to make a cohesive story that's well
paid and you [ __ ] go on youtube
and watch
clips we're literally i've seen the
movie now i've seen the movies i've seen
i've seen the tik-tok clips of it
just yeah i [ __ ] love that movie i
can re-watch it
there's many times yeah well i mean
watch no country or old man it's a very
that's a great film or
just watch the gas station scene on
youtube no don't do that with the zero
context and just be very confused
and be very confused why this guy is
asking this other guy to flip a coin
it's still a great just it's still a
great scene even after the [ __ ]
dialogue he asks people is like the
things he asks people are so creepy
the thing that stands out to me in that
film wasn't the dialogue but it's when
he puts down the candy wrapper
yeah and it just like expands for like a
little bit too long and i've never
i've never been so tense hearing just a
candy wrapper expand yeah i'm just like
what the [ __ ]
also the coolest weapon ever used in a
movie yeah
oh yeah oh [ __ ] gas canisters yeah
it's so [ __ ] cool
because you're like oh this is badass
but [ __ ] he's terrifying but yeah this
is cool though
really scary i forgot tommy lee jones in
that movie as well yeah he's the
main um guy trying to get him right yeah
yeah stuff
like the detective or police guy
whatever the sheriff yeah the sheriff
that's right yeah